une lueur au milieu du Berry presque
endormie on croit réa une soirée entre
voisins mais si on tend un peu l'oreille
il n'en est rien là on fait de la
démocratie là enfin on essaye on apprend
et le mode de scrutin par exemple de
l'élection présidentielle telle qu'il
est actuellement je le trouvais
extrêmement brutal
version causerie au coin du feu nous
sommes chez David enseignant reconverti
à l'exercice des assemblées citoyennes
moi je suis un modérateur un animateur
j'ai plusieurs casquettes bien
évidemment pour essayer de faire en
sorte que le débat soit quand même
régulé qu'on respecte quand même les
thèmes abordés qui sont qui étaient
prévus tout a démarré bien sûr du
pouvoir d'achat de la fiscalité des
impôts de les taxes alors ça c'est le
grand sujet la fiscalité alors quatre
grands thèmes pendant trois heures et
demie les débats sont raisonnés certains
ont même révisé
l'optimisation fiscale qui est la faune
qui est l'afro de légalisé à peu près 18
milliards il faut aussi parler des 457
niches fiscales qui représente à peu
près encore 100 milliards
là on va dire que l'exercice est bien
parce qu'il y a pas trop de monde c'est
limite en termes de personnes non pas
parce que tout le monde a droit à la
parole mais après l'exercice est pas
facile vous voyez les gens ont toujours
tendance à même s'il y a un peu si on
respecte la personne qui parle
je pense que s'il y a vraiment beaucoup
plus de monde ça se termine en
cacophonie c'était secrétaire donc
j'avais l'habitude de recevoir d'écouter
de noter mais pas de m'exprimer mais si
j'ai pas d'accord je le dis mais pas
cela aujourd'hui c'était c'est une
première en fin de compte la parole est
libre sans tabou et sans aucun filtre
les propositions seront remontées sur le
site du grand débat national d'autres
initiatives de particulier sont déjà en
projet